okay thank you and thank you to the
organizers for inviting me for having
this talk I changed my title a bit from
machine learning to data modeling
because actually I used the terms like
synonymously and yeah much learning is a
bit bad word as you all know okay but
what we are going to talk during my 30
minutes so first I will give you a super
short intro about my fandom and that we
have and then we'll go step by step
through the process of machine learning
on our data modelling and where Python
can be helpful and which libraries can
be actually used and after that I hope
there will be time for for questions and
I will not talk too much
so after this presentation I would like
you to know which Python libraries can
be used and actually using really simple
libraries you can actually go from idea
to production and this is not like the
best set up but this is a setup that
works for us so just an example here and
also yeah I would like you to have the
idea that data modeling machine learning
is no magic and actually we can get
really good results with really simple
solutions so as a lot of people on this
conference I have like bio history
behind me and I also studied computer
science and now I work as a data analyst
in tandem and I'm doing a lot of things
from data analysis to data science
through products communication and this
is why I will also be talking about all
of the steps and also how to communicate
results and I work mostly with at
engineering and you will see an example
of data modeling connected with ads so I
hope some of you at least know what
fandom is
and fandom is a company that provides
hubs for communities that are really
fans of something or games or TV series
or movies our users come to our pages to
share their knowledge to share they love
for for those games or or TV series and
we have thousands of those communities
so it goes to thousands of pageviews and
thousands of users every day this is
couple of examples of the communities we
have so as you can see TV shows are here
and we do love data and as you can
imagine from those thousands of
communities thousands of users we have a
lot of time and we gather the data we
have data and different data sources we
have our data warehouse currently it
lives on us free we Cetina and so on
those are data that most of it is
generated on the front end some even
thing what user is doing and we try to
use it to make our pages better so
experience for the user better ok and we
have a lot of different data sources
like GA firebase for apps Google ad
manager for ads metrics and also some
third-party data so moving to the main
part machine learning process we will
start with the idea you can get idea for
the machine learning project from
various sources you can have like super
product manager who just comes up with
another idea every week but actually
most of the ideas that actually went to
production for us came from a data from
data analysis so during some analysis we
observed some trends and we wanted to
understand what's going on and if we can
use those trends or those insights to
actually
improved experience improve our pages
and the first setup I want you to I want
to present to you this is one of the
setups that can be used for data
analysis definitely you can have
different like excel and tableau but
yeah I'm really big fan of Titan and
fortunately we we have setup that we can
use it so we have Jupiter have two
unlife
many of you I think uses Jupiter
notebooks we spice pert because we have
data on this free and it's really easy
to to access the data this way if you
want to scan a lot of it for less
complicated tasks we use pandas and
numpy to wrangle the data map loop Lipsy
burn for visualization like simple
visualization and if we need
interactions we can use bouquet and
totally and last but not least we use
troca and this is time for advertisement
first so stroke is our open source by
the library that we developed in fandom
and what it does it takes the data from
different data sources in a really
simple way so you have seen single
function to actually actually gather the
data and it returns the data in the same
format in our case it's panda's data
frame and why Sroka because troika is
believed to pick up shiny things and we
believe they get a shiny and it takes
the data from different sources so it
fits and currently Soraka is able to
connect to those nine data sources and
another one that is on a way is neo4j
databases and it's open source so if you
want to contribute and add other data
sources
yeah just contact us or create a pull
request okay
but going back to idea so I will use the
actual example of video add completion
rate that we analyze in the company
completion rate is a metric that we use
for example in ads to measure how many
of the all video ads that we showed were
watched to the end and where we when we
were analyzing it we observed that video
at completion differ between different
ad campaigns and it wasn't connected
with length of the ad but it was somehow
connected with users with type of pages
community so there was some signal of
the data and we wanted to see if we can
use it if we can actually get the trend
get the information from the data to
predict better traffic so better traffic
I mean with higher video completion rate
so as I said we would like to have
better traffic however in a case of
machine learning we have to rephrase it
a bit so on each page you that have a
page that has video we would like to
predict if user will complete the video
ad or not so we are rephrased to the
classification binary binary
classification problem okay so we have
our idea now
data preparation I really love this part
I know most of the people like better
than modeling part but I think it's a
lot of fun however what we should look
at during data preparation so first of
all what features should we include in
the model and how those features should
look like so how our data should look
like so algorithms that we want to use
will work well with the data because we
can imagine that we will use
scikit-learn we will use tensorflow we
can use different algorithms like
decision trees and logistic regression
and there's some differences between how
we should prepare the data and what's
okay in the data what's not so during
the data preparation we should consider
this one and about features
about features we can have three types
of features in at least web modeling as
as we do so we can have simple features
that are directly taken from our data so
for example I can do from which country
the user is it's really just asking the
data warehouse where the user is from so
there's like what's like what I call a
simple feature and we have complex
features so for example we have in the
data warehouse information about videos
watched by the user but we don't have
like direct metric number of videos that
user watched in the last three days so
the data is there but we have to Mali
manipulate it a bit regulate to get the
features and but yeah we can definitely
use it and the third thing that we can
consider are the information that we
don't have but we think should could be
important for the goal that we're trying
to achieve let's say we don't have
implemented scrolling of the user on our
page but we think that this is like
super important so we can ask the from
the team can you implement those events
for us we can wait and we can include it
later in the model however I'm not a big
fan of the waiting photos for those
features I think it's better to proceed
with what you have and at the same time
requesting the new data and you can add
them later
when they're ready because the process
of implementing verification the data
dive is really good take takes time okay
and the libraries that we use for data
preparation are not so different again
we use do Peter have eyes for pandas my
blue clip so for some visualizations
roca but also here you can see a sky
learn because I sky learn has a lot of
helpful functions for exam
if you had thousands of features but you
want to focus first on 100 that seems
best and you want to exclude features
that correlate with each other too
strongly there are a lot of functions
that are helpful in this matter I think
I changed okay so the next thing is data
modeling and yet this is the place where
we answer the questions are we able to
find a patter base of the data we have
can we predict what we wanted to predict
in our case better completion rate pages
traffic and as you know there are a lot
of Python libraries that can be used I
am a big fan of SK learn and because I'm
a big fan of simplicity but we use also
tensorflow but there are a lot a lot of
them and you can definitely test others
I think many of you in companies have
different setups so it will also depend
what you're on what your company is
working with what we can do all of us
not depending on what's library we will
use and I will recommend to you it's
starting simple so first of all creating
a benchmark like super simple model with
not sophisticated parameters just to
know what's your benchmark what's your
trash hole that you are trying to be
better than because if you start with
really sophisticated methods with really
complicated models you don't really know
how much better you are then something
that it's really achievable in five
minutes maybe don't but having the
benchmark is really helpful even for
understanding how much insight is in
actual data you are using and the other
thing the other benchmark that I would
recommend to use as businessmen's work
so what are you trying to
improve so for some of the most learning
projects there will not be benchmark
like this like the current situation but
for most web-based or business
benchmarks you can find one so for
example we are trading whole traffic as
a good video at completion rate traffic
and we are targeting all of the ad
campaigns equally so we can use dummy
model with most frequent or defined
class that we have normally on our pages
and another thing about modeling this is
similar to the software development
iterate and improve so when you start
with the simple benchmark simple model
you can then iterate and test different
parameters you have examples what you
can test you have to part use algorithms
you can test various parameters you can
test various set features for example
all features if you have thousands
versus what if you use ten of them maybe
ten will be enough because sometimes you
have huge data sets but the information
you're looking for it's in those ten
features actually and this process at
least partially can be automated like
testing different parameters for example
we can leave computer or server B and
calculate it for us unless we don't know
exactly what metric we are want to look
at because with business projects it's
not always clear if you want to focus on
precision or you want to focus on recall
you would like to have a balance of them
and if you talk with our clients
if those clients are not very familiar
with machine learning it can be hard to
decide which metric is crucial we
set some thresholds but it can be hard
to automate whole process because we
don't we cannot put only precision to
evaluation part and the other thing that
I would like to mention is knowing when
to stop because we can spend a lot of
time modeling and testing and trying to
get inside from the data but sometimes
the information is just not there our
data is great we believe in it we
prepared it the best way it can be but
we just cannot predict what we would
like to based on it and it's nothing
wrong with the data it's nothing wrong
with us so we have to know when to when
to say stop and maybe let's move to a
different project maybe let's think of
other features this project just cannot
work on the day that we have and the
other next step of the process is
communication of the results and if you
work a lot of on classification models
you can think that confusion matrix are
the best way to communicate because you
have predicted do you have actual
classes but if you look at a couple of
examples when you have predicted and
columns here you have actual in columns
and here you have class one and class
two this is just weird
so confusion matrix matrix can get
really confusing especially when you try
to talk to people that don't do
classifications don't do machine
learning at all and actually as I said I
work a lot with products I also talked
with says for example because this
project is like the cross adult sales
other engineering projects so we have to
know how to communicate in a business
way what we achieved with the project
so actually we from the confusion matrix
there is not so far to verbalizing what
we achieved so we can translate the
numbers in confusion matrix for example
here too we created two groups of users
so we divided the traffic to two groups
two users that we think are likely to
watch the ads to the end and users that
we predict that they want and the
difference here based on this model
those two groups differed by 10% points
and from starting value we improved by
4.5% points the numbers are not
important important is that you can
actually tell the results in like people
language not only data science language
and visualizations are really helpful so
here you can see the base value of a lot
of video completion rate and then we
divided the traffic to two groups with
higher and lower a video completion rate
and people do understand that next step
implementation production believe it or
not first our implementation was
implementation of logistic regression
writing the mathematical formula within
code of the page it worked it worked
really well but it was not the best way
to do it the second thing the second
approach we wanted to test decision tree
so we were not able to just paste it
however there is Python library that can
port Mostro from SK learn to JavaScript
and you can load after that on a page
the JavaScript and also it worked
however if you
bigger models it can slow your page down
and we actually tested it on very small
portion of our traffic and the loading
time increased so we didn't want to do
our users that so we have to move to
http Python server we had to we'd love
to do that and how it works currently
step by step we have patent service we
have sorry I'm just using there we have
request sent from the page it goes to
the pilot service then the service purse
parameters it loads the model we have
our models in pickle files on the
service it loads the features runs
predict like in SK learn because this is
an example for for SK learn and prepare
response and it sends response to the
front and on the front there are
implemented decisions what is going on
what is going to happen based on the
results of our prediction and it works
very well here our Python libraries that
we use for it there are the other
solutions for example tensorflow
also have similar setup that you can use
at the moment it was implemented this
was better solution for us I don't
remember why exactly but it was yeah and
the last step that I want to talk about
is monitoring and this is super
important I have couple of points why
and how can we monitor what can we
monitor during attack during a model
having model in production but how we do
it currently so first of all we have
graph Anna looking looking at our
service so the Python service that is
taking a request and giving respond
responses and doing the prediction so we
know that everything is healthy from the
technical side and we also have
monitoring from more product more Bolin
modeling parts we use it currently mode
because it's in our company setup
it supports SQL in Python and it reports
directly on slack and what we are
looking at during this modeling we are
looking if the model is not worsening
with time because models get worse with
time and we can observe if still we
observe the differences between the two
groups what is important for us
especially in this project is to observe
it the sizes of the groups that's not
decrease because if even if we have a
group that have 100% of VCR but the
group is super small like 1% of the
traffic it's not useful for sales they
cannot put any ads in this traffic
because it's just too small so it's
better for us to have like a 50/50 or 30
70 division of the traffic so we need to
look at the size usually when we roll
out the model we first check it in
single geo or percentage of one geo just
to see if it performs well how the
service is doing so we also can check if
next rollouts in different years work
correctly and yeah it shows us if the
whole infrastructure's work so again
health check like or fun I do yeah and
this is all about the steps and this is
how we did it and we did couple of
projects this way and I hope after this
talk you get the feeling that all of
these steps are not really hard and
those libraries are not very complicated
and we actually were able to do it to
production and it's working and and
fight on this a great
language to to use for for such project
and the presentation isn't github and
yeah we don't have openings now but we
will have in q1 so if you're interested
this is an address and I hope you learn
something or even single thought from
what I said will be helpful for your
project and if you have any questions or
feedback yeah you can ask them now or
you can email me on LinkedIn me or grab
me later okay thank you
[Applause]